un mode au sport avec la deuxième
édition de la tremblaysienne dimanche
événement important puisqu'il s'agit de
la première course à pied des yvelines
depuis l'épidémie de coronavirus et le
confinement est le rendez-vous s'est
tenue dimanche au tremblay sur mauldre
au programme deux parcours de 5 et 10 km
une aubaine pour les coureurs étant
donné le peu d'événements sportifs
maintenu les propos recueillis
rassemblés par patrick jacques de
dixmude et bixente n'a rien senti steban
cette année nous avons 110 coureurs au
départ sur le 5 km et 10 km avec par
contre elle un versement total de 80 %
hors département qui viennent de tout le
grand paris voire même plus loin
moi ma dernière course et au mois de
mars donc juste avant le corridor
effectivement est bon le vis comme un
comme un événement sympa on va d'abord
prendre du plaisir
non non c'est très bien et c'est bien
mise en place aujourd'hui donc ça va
être ça va être top
le port du masque de la houle et
distanciation sociale ne peuvent pas
être respecté et tenu donc sur la zone
de départ et après la zone d'arrivée
après le le temps de récupération
nécessaire et réglementaires